nous accueillons notre invité du samedi
20h ce soir Jocelyne Rousseau bonsoir
alors Jocelyne vous êtes médecin
généraliste à Pierrefitte en
Seine-Saint-Denis depuis 30 ans vous
aimez la banlieue vous adorez votre
métier mais depuis quelques temps vous
avez dû transformer votre cabinet en
véritable forteresse pour éviter les
agressions tout à fait
le risque c'est qu'à terme il y a plus
de personnel de santé dans certaines
portions du territoire en fait oui
ça nous fait travailler dans ces
conditions
alors je sinon vous êtes né le 20
décembre 1955 à Tunis à l'époque encore
français pour pour un an protectorat
votre père était représentant de
commerce votre mère professeur de
français
enfance pied-noir quoi sympa
les grands les grands déjeuner du
dimanche
mais en juin 1967 la guerre des Six
Jours qui oppose Israël à l'Égypte à la
Jordanie à la scierie oblige vos parents
à quitter la Tunisie et du jour au
lendemain vous retrouvez dans un avion
direction Sarcelles c'est pas évident
parce que d'abord les diplômes de votre
mère n'étaient pas reconnus sur le
territoire français
a continué à être représentants
mais bon vous prenez ça bien vous faites
votre cinquième sans problème et vous
restez dans les premiers de la classe
alors vous aimez la banlieue vous dites
Sarcelles dans les années 70 c'était la
campagne avec des vaches et des moutons
quand je me suis installée il y a 30 ans
j'ai coutume de dire que j'étais presque
médecin
de cité alors après un bac scientifique
au lycée de Sarcelles vous décidez de
faire médecine alors pas une spécialité
vous faites médecin généraliste
alors vous dites en tant que médecin
généraliste je ne soigne pas mes
patients je prends soin de
parce que notre boulot de médecin et de
professionnelle de santé dans ces
banlieues difficiles effectivement on a
envie
de s'occuper des gens on fait quelques
fois leur course moi jusqu'à il y a deux
trois ans les gamins de la cité venaient
faire leurs devoirs dans ma salle de
vente en 1980 vous vous installez donc à
Pierrefitte en banlieue important de
travailler en banlieue vous dites
j'avais pas envie d'être psychiatre pour
chien
à l'époque vous êtes médecin de campagne
vous allez chercher votre lait à la
ferme faites votre marché chez les
commerçants du coin votre porte est
toujours ouverte les gens passent pour
donner des nouvelles demander un conseil
c'était très convivial et ça c'est
totalement perdu malheureusement les
choses changent assez rapidement d'abord
l'urbanisation galopante c'est-à-dire
que les gens se retrouvent entassés dans
des dans des barres d'immeubles et un
appauvrissement général qui fait que les
commerçants s'en vont c'est à dire que
les bouchers les boulangers les épiciers
ferment donc on se retrouve avec un
grand commerce
et puis plus rien plus de vie dans la
ville alors parallèlement la sécurité
augmente les volets à l'arrachée trafic
de drogue un jour vous faites voler
votre sac à main dans la rue mais
finalement
votre mission reste malgré tout
enthousiasmante bien sûr je veux dire
que notre boulot quotidien c'est d'aider
les gens de leur parler quand
une mère africaine vient me dire tu as
raison ma fille ne sera pas excisée
c'est une grande joie dans ma vie quand
il y a une maman qui vient me faire
signer le livret de son gamin le livret
scolaire de son gamin parce que parce
que je lui ai fait faire ses devoirs de
grammaire et de conjugaison c'est un
grand bonheur le problème c'est qu'en
juin 2016 un soir à 20h vous faites
dévaliser en sortant du cabinet de
gamins qui vous laisse par terre et
cette fois c'est pas un vulgaire vol de
sac à main c'est-à-dire qu'en fait vous
vous rendez compte qui vous attendez à
la sortie du cabinet jusqu'à présent on
avait toujours eu nous les
professionnels de santé l'impression
d'être au mauvais endroit au mauvais
moment et là depuis quelques années
depuis 2007 effectivement on a
l'impression que les agressions nous
sont dédiées on est une cible
privilégiée de même que les policiers
ont été une cible puis les pompiers puis
les enseignants maintenant ce sont les
professionnels de santé
le 24 octobre 2009 à midi vous sortez du
cabinet avec votre ordinateur portable
un sac à main votre valise de médecin
quand deux jeunes cagoulés vous sautent
dessus et en une seconde vous retrouvez
coucher par terre la tête plaquée contre
le sol un pistolet sur la tempe
on est attaqué et même tabasser passer à
tabac quelquefois
en plus des gosses de 13 14 ans vous
avez soigné torcher vacciné quoi et ça
c'est très frustrant et c'est vrai que
ça nous met en colère alors en tout vous
serez agressé 17 fois
le 18e c'est lui février dernier donc là
une patiente vous signale par téléphone
que deux hommes cagoulé vous attendent
devant le cabinet donc ça vous évite
évidemment cette 18e agression enfin 17
c'est beaucoup quand même ça commence à
faire je vais rentrer dans le livre des
records
et pourtant vous baissez pas les bras
vous dites on va pas tout plaquer pour
une poignée de petits cons
des gens adorables et que vraiment on en
a ras-le-bol que une poignée de petits
voyous empoisonne la vie de tout le
monde on est en colère parce que ces
gens méritent autre chose ils vivent
dans une grande précarité ils vivent
dans un grand désarroi et que si les
professionnels de santé partent mais que
vont-ils devenir pourquoi les 95% de
gens bien arrivent pas à faire respecter
la loi aux 5% de délinquants parce que
c'est délinquant sont des vrais
délinquants que pierrefitestin et ça
fait partie de la plaque tournante de la
drogue et que c'est quand même des une
population qui est très très violente
c'est 95% n'ont aucun pouvoir sur les
5%. eux aussi sont agressés quand on
parle dans nos clientèle
on trouverament une personne qui n'a pas
été agressée ça n'existe pas vous savez
comment se finissent toutes mes
consultations à l'heure actuelle c'est
Jocelyne faites attention à vous malgré
tout vous n'abandonnez pas ces gens-là
donc vous occupez depuis 30 ans non
on ne partira pas mais ceci dit on
commence à s'épuiser et on a besoin
qu'on nous vienne en aide
oui je pense
alors comment est-ce qu'on peut
expliquer que c'est que ces jeunes
malfrats s'en prennent à du personnel de
santé en dehors du fait qu'il vous
croirait chez que vous êtes une
profession c'est quand même bizarre
parce que vous êtes là pour les soigner
c'est quand même fou quoi
on a pas d'explication c'est vrai que
dans le fantasme de ces jeunes voyous on
doit avoir beaucoup d'argent ce n'est
pas vrai du tout je veux dire les
professionnels de santé en
Seine-Saint-Denis vous savez qu'il y a
plus de 20% des gens qui ont la CMU plus
de 10% des gens qui ont l'aide médicale
d'État il y a plus de 20% des gens qui
ont souffrent d'une maladie à 100%, donc
il y a déjà au moins 50% des gens qui ne
nous paient plus pour ma part depuis
deux ans je n'ai plus d'espèces du tout
je refuse les paiements ça vous oblige à
prendre des mesures de sécurité
fini vous balader avec un ordinateur une
valise de médecin ou un sac à main
ensuite paiement électronique les
horaires vous arrêtez à 18h ou d'arrêter
à 21h ce qui fait que votre chiffre
d'affaires baisse de toute façon
largement ou les plus marcher la nuit
dans Pierrefitte quoi bon comment savoir
un peu peur la nuit quand même on est
téméraire mais quand même pas
complètement complètement barjot alors
plus de visites à domicile qu'on vous ne
connaissez pas les gens chez qui on vous
demande d'aller
et puis visiophone à l'entrée du cabinet
alors il y a un problème le médecin de
banlieue est une espèce on voit de
disparition tout à fait Pierrefitte est
une commune qui enregistre le plus fort
taux de natalité en France la dernière
pédiatre vient de partir nous n'avons
plus de pédiatre
mille habitants ce qui fait 1 pour 3000
alors que la moyenne nationale c'est un
pour 1000
nous sommes un désert médical reconnu et
c'est pour ça qu'on demande de l'aide
parce que nous on est là les
professionnels de santé on est là depuis
30 ans on retrousse les manches depuis
30 ans on n'a plus à faire la preuve de
notre engagement dans cette banlieue on
a plus la faire la preuve de notre
attachement vis-à-vis de cette
population alors bon sang et des nous on
est au bord du burn out on va tous se
barrer et que va devenir cette
population
il faut nous aider
la moyenne d'âge est 55 ans dans le
personnel de santé de Pierrefitte par
exemple comme il n'y a pas de nouveau
dans 10 ans il y en aura plus si on
n'est pas tous partis avant quand vous
dites aidez-nous ça veut dire quoi
l'état nous doit la sécurité
on veut absolument que cette sécurité
soit assurée pour tout le monde pour nos
patients pour nous nous ne voulons plus
vivre dans des forteresses nous voulons
vivre comme avant il y a des maisons de
santé comme ça où on regroupe les
médecins pour les pour les protéger
d'une certaine façon mais c'est quoi une
maison de santé c'est un supermarché de
la médecine et alors on va faire comme
avec les supermarchés alimentaires on va
faire disparaître le petit commerce nous
on est un tissu sanitaire de proximité
on est là tout le temps auprès des gens
vous dites se faire traiter de sale [ __ ]
et devenu quotidien et le pire c'est
qu'on s'est habitué
ça la violence verbale ça fait partie de
notre quotidien
effectivement je préfère me faire
traiter de sale [ __ ] que de me faire
mettre un flingue sur la tête
mais c'est quand même pas très
confortable
oui tout à l'heure on était dans des
débats finalement un peu théoriques la
première partie non on redescend dans la
vraie vie
ce qui est en cause c'est
moins d'ailleurs la police que l'école
la justice parce que c'est arrêté des
enfants ne pas savoir quoi en faire ou
les relâcher tout de suite alors qu'ils
ont commis des délits des délits graves
c'est c'est
grand totalement vent le travail de la
police et voilà
c'est l'efforts éducatifs qui est encore
comment apprend-on
aux enfants à respecter des règles
encore une fois la police fait son
travail mais si vous arrêtez un voyou et
que le lendemain matin il est retourné
chez lui sans être puni bon si les
parents sont totalement des
responsabilisés si on accepte qu'à 11
ans ou 12 ans un enfant soit déscolarisé
dans un pays où la l'obligation scolaire
va jusqu'à 16 ans que croyez-vous qu'il
va devenir si les petits trafics ça
rapporte plus que de travailler donc
vous voyez bien c'est un problème très
profond de désintégration sociale
effectivement la sécurité c'est
important qu'il faut augmenter la
sécurité dans nos banlieues mais ça ne
suffit pas il faut résoudre le problème
du chômage il faut résoudre le problème
des ghettos il faut résoudre il faut
avoir des mesures préventives c'est une
urgence monsieur
résoudre le problème du chômage ça se
fait pas d'un goût de baguette magique
mais
néanmoins 1 ça n'est pas parce qu'on est
chômeur voilà
j'ai vécu dans un milieu pauvre et
vraiment
inadmissible inadmissible dans mon
milieu dans mon milieu de pauvres que on
puisse commettre un un délivé je vais
vous raconter une histoire un jour
j'étais tout jeune ma grand-mère chez le
coiffeur régulièrement et puis il y
avait des bandes dessinées de vieilles
bandes dessinées et un jour j'en ai
emporté une et ma grand-mère s'en est
rendu compte je crois que je n'ai jamais
passé un aussi mauvais moment et elle a
fait quelque chose qui était très
judicieux elle m'a elle m'a accompagnée
chez le coiffeur pour lui rendre
cette qui ne valait rien le coiffeur
c'est OK et il a souri gentiment mais
j'ai eu tellement honte que je n'ai plus
jamais envie de de recommencer mais
voilà moi vous avez dit tout à l'heure
je suis considéré comme un maire
sécuritaire mais j'en vois en même temps
les limites il faut changer profondément
la ville si on ne lutte pas contre la
ghettoïsation on ne fait rien vous voyez
moi va commencer par être mère d'un
arrondissement à Lyon où il y avait une
cité sans doute un peu comme la vôtre
s'appelle La Duchère à Lyon et cette
cité je voyais que elle se paupérisait
de jour en jour les gens qui entraient
dans les HLM ils avaient de moins en
moins de revenus ils vivaient tous de
l'assistant venez si je laisse à aller
comme ça dans quelques années c'est la
catastrophe absolue et donc on a fait un
effort terrible pour effectivement
reconstruire des Molières à certains de
barres reconstruire dans ces cités faire
en sorte qu'on puisse construire du
logement social au cœur de la ville de
manière à remixer les populations parce
que si vous avez tous les pauvres d'un
côté puis des îlots et des ghettos de
riches de l'autre ça marche pas Jocelyne
merci d'avoir témoigné j'espère que ça
servira à quelque chose
en tous les cas bravo bravo pour votre
courage et pour être sûr de ne rien
rater de innarditude abonnez-vous et
mettez un pouce bleu